so yesterday five percent gdp really
looks like confirmation of what we've
been talking about all fall and winter
which is this divergence the US economy
powering ahead while the rest of the
world is slowing down what are the
consequences of divergence for emerging
markets so the major consequences of
divergence for emerging markets is that
monetary policy in the advanced world
will go in different directions the US
will tighten Europe will continue to
loosen and Japan will be uber loose so
exchange rates currencies are going to
move and the emerging world is going to
have to navigate a lot more currency
volatility I talked to me a bit about
Russia yesterday S&P said its sovereign
rating is on the brink of junk obviously
Vladimir Putin is doing a lot of things
to try to rescue the sell-off in the
ruble how does Russia get through the
winter here so first of all it will be
downgraded to junk simply because they
don't have enough reserves to meet all
the requirements okay and it's not just
protecting their creditworthiness its
meeting external debt is slowing down
capital outflows it is stabilizing the
currency it is meeting input demands
when their exports have been cut by half
so 400 billion may sound like a lot but
it's not enough for these multiple
objectives so something is going to have
to give and I think a couple of things
are going to give one is the credit
rating and secondly controls I think
what what is looking at is recession
inflation periodic pressure on the
currency and mr. Putin having to make a
very important decision as to whether to
re-engage with the West or not